hello i'm gavin
i'm dan we're the slow-mo guys this
video is sponsored by the terminal list
starring chris pratt on prime video it
was made with the help of navy seals for
as much realism as possible a very
realistic show we're back at the school
of mines we made a video here a few
years ago and to be honest we made a
real mess of the place yeah
i'm surprised they let us back oh me too
me too but in that video we discovered
how cool shaped charges look in slo-mo
yeah that's something navy seals are
very used to using shape charges for
multiple purposes and uh we're going to
be concentrating more on that this time
with a especially with the copper solid
copper lined shaped charges which is
what the enable seals would use so to
that end they've helped us prep for this
video last time we got up to about 200
000 frames a second this time we hope to
fly past that and get some extremes get
into the millions ideally that is
serious that is very serious so why
don't we take a look at our cameras and
then get blasting sounds good all right
all right our first subject is a door
pointed at said door is the phantom
t3610 it's about 120 000 frames a second
full width is the same as 720p or about
1280 pixels across and we'll be using
that a lot today for all the subjects
that we want to film a lot of horizontal
action
this is where we start getting a bit
extreme with stuff this is the shimatsu
hpv x and this can go way above a
million
in black and white way above a million
how does it do that well
the way the way the compromise is that
it will only take 256 pictures but you
know play that back at 25 i'll be about
10 seconds of footage so uh let's take a
look at the explosives navy seals use
shape charges like this for several
different purposes they come in lots of
different sizes for lots of different
reasons this particular one is the same
sort of size that they'd be using for
breaching a door like we're going to be
doing this one's quite small and has a
thing called standoff the copper cone
has to be the correct distance away from
what it's trying to make a hole in now
this particular one has to be placed on
here
i'm going to place it about here which
is right next to the locking mechanism
and hopefully we're going to smash
through everything we need to so for
this one we don't need any standoff this
particular shape charge doesn't require
the best standoff is actually flush
basically we've got this lock here at
the moment it's open
oh it's meaty
oh
the whole bar moves so that's now lock
you can't open it again now that shows
you that then part of the mechanism
we're going to try and hit with the
shape charges about here so what the
navy seals would do is they create a
hole with the shaped charge first and
then pack it with more explosives to
create a bigger hole you know the door
will still work you think the bar will
move i think we're being a bit
optimistic but uh we'll see we'll see
good slo-mo first door functionality
second yeah absolutely
all right
let's see they've fixed they fixed it
yeah
you may remember that we blew this puppy
out last time and knocked a
six-figure phantom onto the floor
everything away look at the camera
oh my god oh my god we got a phantom
down yeah it was sat behind the window
wasn't it and it shoved it onto the
floor because it blew the window it
actually did save the footage the shape
charge is in the right place in the door
we've netted up
and uh
locked the door so hopefully once it's
blown we'll be able to open the door
but let's retreat
all right we're at our safe place i've
got my button
just have to not miss the trigger
fire in the hole fire in the hole fire
the hole
oh that bird it's not that bad from up
here yeah it's always a little bit
nerve-wracking when you're so far from
the cameras oh wow well we've made our
hole look that's such a neat little hole
oh it's wait it's melted the dial off oh
my god no way
it's just blown the handle off oh and
that's sheared that's done
the actual mechanism has dropped down as
well it doesn't even line up you
couldn't even weld that on
oh
look at what damage is
and what's interesting is the fact that
the handle was only there
so it's had enough power to blow it
apart blow oh smash that
alright well let's see if it's function
correctly the whole thing's gone what
the whole box the whole lock box so wait
i wonder if it it oh
is it this guy's so brittle oh it's just
blown apart but placement wise you
absolutely nailed it should we see if it
can open
no way
yeah we did it so it unlocked it but we
just didn't have a way to yeah we didn't
have the handle if the handle hadn't
blown off that would have been a success
that is that was really cool that was
wicked i honestly wasn't expecting much
with the functionality of unlocking the
door yeah but that worked really well
yeah that was really good that was my
first breaking into a bank bolt
oh jeez look at that it's amazing oh and
the shock wave you can see it going on
the on the right there yeah you can like
just as it changes what the background
is you can see it
warping it
that's wicked
oh do you see what it's when it speeds
up it kind of get like wobbles around
what happened there was that oh it's the
reverberation because you're inside the
vault a little bit
it just annihilated that little bolt and
just splattered it all over the wall
yeah i'm just it was so brittle i
expected it to just kind of cut a hole
straight through but it just annihilated
the whole thing you can see chunks of it
going left so the shock wave shot right
and the chunks of the lock shot left
after some of it bounced off the wall i
think though
the triggering method for the shimatsu
camera didn't work on that one so we'll
hopefully have it on the next shot
i honestly think that when we make our
videos some of the most satisfying stuff
is just
how many x can x go through and here we
are it's a good formula okay in this
case our x is this steel plate which is
the same thickness and weight as a
marine door on a ship so you know what
the navy seals will be using these
charges to get through essentially and
we've seen how strong steel is for
example when we
shot a steel ball
yeah it's really hard really strong
which shows you the power of these
charges now what i'm curious about is
fine one one door you know absolutely
fine no problem just a breeze two with
an air gap between because the thing is
what happens is the jet will lose some
of its power and penetrative
capabilities it starts to break apart
and then three
so i reckon we'll get through the first
two and then the third i don't have any
faith so we've got the 4k running at 4k
1000 frames a second
might get an exit might get one frame of
that we've got the t3610
at 63 000 frames a second
i've got the shimatsu it's a million so
massive coverage you're saying these
numbers like just like yeah half a
million here millionaire
i'll throw some more numbers out how
about this right the copper jet the tip
of it okay reaches 10 kilometers a
second that's how fast it goes right and
it gets there in about 40 micro seconds
right from this first initial detonation
okay and that's an acceleration of 25
million g's
and a human will pass out like eight
typically if you're if you're solid
eight or nine you know jet pilots 25
million g's yeah out of there yeah and
if if it was possible to go past the 10
kilometers a second yeah it would reach
the speed of light in around one and a
half seconds
if it just kept going that's like
at my limit of comprehension i feel like
it's like i can only just visualize that
that is insane well that's why we've got
half a million frames in a million
frames so uh let's set it up
bar in the hole fire in the hole fire in
the hole
always satisfying oh moment of truth
oh look at all this damage here oh it's
exactly what you said
look how the holes get smaller there's
just a tiny little bit that came out
there a little a little exit wound so
you could potentially see it getting
skinnier between do you think if this
was here it would have gone the same
distance yeah
i don't think i don't think i think it's
the distance that's the problem not the
amount of steel it's going through on
the first plate you've got all of this
like tiny little bits here yeah and
that's all stopped and then on the third
one it's barely happened and you're only
letting a tiny amount through that is
gonna be so interesting this is so cool
at that speed it treats metal like
liquid
just it just looks like someone set off
fireworks
very nice and sparkly though yeah it's
really cool
bloody bright okay so we probably
shouldn't place the camera behind
the shape charge anymore because it just
comes out sideways and covers everything
up but you can see that
reverberation between the last two
plates
you can see the the copper just kind of
dispersing and going everywhere it's
like a mix of the copper and the steel
that it's kind of annihilated because
we've got our million frames a second
camera running these are exposed
slightly brighter just so we can see the
context okay so this is million frames a
second oh wow that shimatsu makes it
look like butter that's so cool you can
really see what's happening can't you
we've kept in all the detail the actual
shape charge and you see it coming
through see what look at the the
brightness of the shape charge it gets
brighter on impact yeah as soon as you
open your mouth i knew what you were say
isn't that cool yeah it's wicked have
you ever seen a shape charge this slow i
have not this is the slowest i've seen
one this is astonishing yeah this is
gonna be really useful for people in my
old job
uh we used to learn how they work and uh
this would be really useful footage for
them to see okay we've replaced steel
plates with
plates
this has been very confusing okay
throughout the whole day this charge
will have standoff from the first plate
mainly so we have a nice clean shot of a
shaped charge going off on its own on
the super fast camera fire the hole fire
in the hole fire in the hole
oh do you hear that like
ping sound
is this shrapnel yeah you get a bit of
plate so how many plates do you reckon
it's gone through oh
[Laughter]
there's all of them now you were worried
that because they used ceramic for armor
well it was not just the fact that they
used ceramic for armor it's also the
fact that it had to travel such a big
distance before it first hit the first
one so what we'll learn from the slow-mo
is whether the shape charge made it or
whether it was just
the first plate
exploding and taking everything out i
tell you what though you can see that
the earlier plates are very small now
yeah and the end plates seem to be a bit
bigger so it's going to be small smaller
bigger bigger bigger bigger big i think
this is the outside of the shape charge
like the the shell part of it oh just
like what is that made of like a steel
is that it is that just the back of it
oh no it's a bit of the clamp it's the
bloody clamp yeah plastic
if that's plastic it got sent
down to the wood
yeah there's bits of metal here
oh my god
i wanna know what it is
this video is gonna be half an hour long
now
[Laughter]
oh god this is
in there actually
that's it that's part of the shape
charge isn't it it turned into a knife
and
bloody
shot down into that word
okay so what's your predictions for uh
well you can see what number plate the
shape charge got to so this is the first
plate one tiny pieces two three four
six seven eight
nine
okay let's let's verify okay
let's see if we can tell what happened
on this one ready yeah three two one
not really not really but lovely
colorful
very nice shrapnel lots of lots of
shrapnel
wow
wow
looks like they're cool
it is how many plates is that okay let's
count it back
that's really cool though it's really
cool it like in two
three
four five six seven eight i shouldn't
have gone for the extra one
when i went nine i was i should have
stuck to my guns
it's so bright i love how it flares
though it looks like uh something
re-entering the atmosphere isn't it yeah
just like the flare across the lens the
shape of the plate dissipates the
explosion as the shape of the plate is
yeah the plate keeps its shape so it
goes through makes an explosion looks
like that goes through makes a smaller
one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
plate plate yeah yeah yeah exactly that
wasn't wicked okay and now the shimazu
that's cool oh
man
the spread is really interesting so it
actually comes out oh and there's like a
reverse that is that is wicked right
when it comes out the first place it
looks like a big cloud but then it goes
to the next plate and you know that
underneath that cloud is just a copper
jet piercing right in the middle you see
i mean at this moment that is the copper
jet coming through
and then the same thing happens again
it's like little bits of metal and
copper that uh you see little tiny
fragments like little meteors going and
hitting the first plate and then they
just
explode as soon as they do
it's interesting i i felt like the black
and white would sort of take away some
of the coolness of this footage
but
the detail is there
so every frame of this that moves is a
millionth of a second
okay so because that shot had standoff
we now have a clean million frames a
second shot of the shape charge
oh whoa that was quick still
oh i'll tell you what let me do you one
bit how about five billion
wait what five million
whoa
no way no
that's amazing that is the cream
that is incredible you can literally see
the inversion of the copper cone in the
explosion you can see the explosion
begin and then the inversion happened
from the back because obviously it's the
cone shape there you can see it happen
from the back making its way forward and
accelerate past because we've only ever
been filming at lower frame rates we've
never really seen this bit but this bit
is amazing just watching the the center
get blasted through yeah that's what has
the effect on the target is that because
within there is you know a copper jet
that's like quite thin
but like to see it to actually see the
science sort of in front of your eyes
rather than just having it explained to
you like i have because i've never seen
that before
and our team at the school of mines has
absolutely nailed that exposure look at
that shot that's perfect so what does it
look like it's going to happen that
looks like we're going to catch an
explosion in water to be honest pretty
much so the seal team sometimes refer to
the the copper jet that comes out as a
heated carrot so we're going to try and
catch the carrot in some water water's a
weird one i don't know what's going to
happen yeah i've never seen this done i
predict that you'll see the jet form
it'll hit the water and then i have no
idea what's gonna happen
fire the hole fire in the hole far in
the hole
different sound that time still a pretty
full cup yeah it doesn't seem like we've
displaced much with our carrot it can't
have been a large carrot oh it did just
fall in
what
oh it didn't initiate that so the
detonator went off the dna went off yeah
and the uh shape just fell out that's
exactly right hmm
that's that's what happened that was a a
failed detonation yeah that's just the
misfire all right catch the carrot take
two okay we may sacrifice the sea stand
fire in the hole
that's more like it
that's the noise you want to hear
look at all that it's just gone our tube
where where's any of it oh it's oh
there's water everywhere goodness me
potentially we caught the hot carrot and
immediately lasted yeah
yeah that has created absolute shards i
didn't think it would do that you know
it was so powerful that it had to just
escape and it couldn't escape up that
way even with an open top yeah it was
that incompressible that's amazing looks
fake this is some thick plastic as well
look how thick that is that's chunky
oh
i didn't even see any any flash or
anything nothing it just says it's gone
it's as if we put explosives in the tube
itself and just blown up a tube of water
look at the c-stand
[Music]
wow
oh my goodness it was like a it's like
it's like a smoke monster it was all the
way down through the through the tube
and then it like
did the crack beat the explosion
so look at where i cracked
oh it's like right in the middle oh
weird that's unexpected well it's like
by middle i just mean like not at the
bottom or the top that cracks incredibly
fast as well doesn't it look at the
first frame of it it's complete it's
like looking into a sun
in terms of how it flares the entire
place flares the lens flares the tube
immediately gone and then
it's like a mushroom cloud on top
explosions are usually incredibly bright
yeah and the water really takes that
away and like makes it completely
abstract the shock wave the cavitation
the fog and the smoke there's like
there's so much happening and it was
pretty much the perfect length tube
[Music]
it looks like a meteor hitting the
planet doesn't it it looks like that's
what that's what would happen if a
meteor hit the ocean and it's so
interesting how none of the brightness
translates underwater at this exposure
you can sort of see the uh the jet in
its like grayed out darkened state but
what you're really seeing is that
reflection of the shock wave yeah and
then it just quickly asserts itself and
annihilates the tube
well we can't be disappointed with that
of course not that was some great
footage oh come on explosions blowing
through things
really high speeds every i really didn't
know what to expect for most of those
well considering i know quite a lot
about shaped charges and things like
that yeah you know i knew it was gonna
happen with the steel i had a good idea
right
no idea with the water at all yeah all
the plates or the you know the plate
plates plate plates it just it was
really cool and surprising i think the
water was my favorite one just because
it was
but to get the most destructive one and
there was just so many elements to it
yeah it's crazy there's a lot going on
it's also really exciting to
use a bunch of
very specialized photographic equipment
that's pretty much designed exactly for
this looking at just the beginning of an
explosion yeah stuff that on our
phantoms are just like the sun
you're just like seeing it
amazing
well big thanks to the terminal list on
prime video for sponsoring this video
the terminal list is based on a book of
the same name by jack carr a former navy
seal and also served as an executive
producer on the show it really shows
because the show has a massive
commitment to authenticity and it leans
heavily on military consultants and has
over 25 military veterans in front of
the camera so they really knew what they
were doing yeah big commitment make sure
you check out all the action-packed
episodes of the terminal list starring
chris pratt on prime video here's a
little clip this was a targeted attack
on alpha platoon
12 seals lost and no one in command even
issues a statement i want to know why
whoever set us up we need to find them
what's the play
is it true your fugitive is a navy seal
i have nothing left to lose
the terminal list new series now
streaming on prime video well there we
have it big old thanks to the colorado
school of minds for putting up with us
again letting us just blow the place up
please please invite us back yeah we'll
try and come back again if they let us
make sure you subscribe to the channel
if you like slo-mo and why don't you
watch the video that we made right here
last time
if you can handle it
if you can
melt it handle it that's not my vote
okay
keep it going one more
clearly plan those two let's get another
one
it's a safe bet that you've
enjoyed yeah okay you'd enjoy the video
we'll see you next time okay